une nouvelle gouvernance locale la mise
en place de la transition écologique
vivre dignement ce sont les grands axes
du programme 10 miles havane l'actuel
conseiller municipal d'opposition veut
notamment créer une commission de la
transition écologique piloté par le
premier adjoint
cette commission et sera ouverte par
tirage au sort aux habitants est aussi
ouverte aux habitants et habitantes
désireux de vouloir intégrer cette
commission et nous avons la chance à
maurepas d'avoir des citoyens experts
dans certain nombre de domaines ce sera
une occasion aussi d impliquer une liste
presque entièrement renouvelé sept
colistiers repartent d'airial ismaïl à
vannes
nous avons souhaité vraiment un
renouvellement au niveau de notre liste
est impliqué des hommes et des femmes
qui ont pas l'habitude de la pratique de
la vie politique à l'échelle locale et
donc du coup nous avons réussi notre
pari puisque notre appel au
rassemblement a été vraiment entendu
parmi les nouveaux des fonctionnaires
des chefs de projets de jeunes
travailleurs à noël inspectrice dans
l'aide sociale pourrait se voir confier
les affaires sociales un projet social
et solidaire pour moi la solidarité
effectivement entre tous les citoyens
elle est très importante
les plus forts doivent aider les plus
faibles dans une commune c'est aussi le
rôle de la mairie et des élus mettre en
place un transport à disposition des
personnes qui en auraient besoin ça
qu'on se rendre à des rendez-vous
médicaux soit pour se rendre à des
activités prochaine réunion de la liste
maurepas dynamique et solidaire jeudi 5
mars à 20 heures au cesa de la jo en
2014 la liste d'ismaïla vannes avait
rassemblé 13 % des suffrages